Let's go to our caller from the nine one three
area code.
Who's calling today from nine one three?
Hi, David.
Can you hear me?
Yes, I can.
Who's this?
Cool.
This is Andrew from the Boston area.
My question for you is, what can be done to
sever the ties between property taxes and
school funding?
That's my final question for.
Yeah.
This is a great question, because you have
this perpetuating cycle in a lot of areas
where the richer areas with higher property
values are often collecting more property
taxes.
And those taxes are used to fund schools which
make those schools better, which makes more
people want to move into those areas, which
often drives up property values even more,
making the properties less accessible.
And you get situations that essentially mean
the interview earlier this week with Daniel
Markovits about the idea of a meritocracy,
not not being what we had, not also not being
ideal in its extreme form, but also not being
what we have is is related exactly to this
issue.
So I've seen different proposals.
I mean, in to put it very simply, you can
find other funding.
You could you could just say property taxes
are no longer going to be directly funding
the schools.
So, for example, property taxes may be pooled
or partially pooled at the state level and
then redistributed out now not 100 percent.
So if you have a place with really high property
taxes, they would send a portion of the taxes
to the state.
A place with lower property tax receipts would
send a portion to the state, and then the
state would sort of redistribute more evenly
to try to improve the schools that that are
not quite so good.
But, of course, the people that are paying
the higher property taxes are going to resist
that.
They're going to say, wait, I'm paying more
so that my kids can go to good schools.
And by living here, I'm actually helping somebody
somewhere else and that people are going to
be furious about that.
So if the question is how could it be done
mathematically, you'd redistribute.
You have a common pool and redistribute.
If the question is how do you do it politically?
I have no idea.
Yeah.
Are there any leaders right now who are running
with this kind of at the top of their platform
that we can be promoting?
That's my second question.
And it's kind of hard not not that I'm aware
of.
I mean, know it's it's certainly possible.
I'm not aware of anybody who's who's making
that their issue, but that doesn't mean it
doesn't exist.
All right, great.
Thanks, David.
All right, great to hear from you.
Excellent question.
Thank you for the call.
Let's go to our caller from the nine eight
five area code.
Who's calling today from 985?
Hi, my name is Christian Man, and I'm calling
from Baton Rouge, Louisiana.
What's going on, Christian?
Hey, how you doing?
It's kind of hard to hear you, but my question
was, so I listen to you and I also listen
to Ben Shapiro show.
OK.
And so it seems like you guys on some of the
same topics, like, for instance, like the
Trump speeches, you all have the exact opposite
points of view on this.
Shocking.
So I guess my question is, how is it how are
those opposite points of view from the two
sides, like reconcilable in the current climate
where I don't think they are?
I mean, I think that it's sadly intractable.
I don't I don't watch Ben Shapiro, so I don't
know what he said.
But earlier this week, I covered Tucker Carlson's
reaction to Trump's Mount Rushmore speech.
And Tucker Carlson, I think, called it maybe
Trump's best speech ever.
And what was so interesting to me about it
was it was the speech of rhetoric.
It was not a speech of policy.
So if the question if what you want to see
in a speech is what accomplishments does Trump
claim from his first term and what is he going
to do in his second term?
You didn't get that in Trump's speech.
What you got from Trump's speech was dog whistle,
red meat rhetoric about we're fighting Marxists
and all these crazy, you know, straw men that
don't exist.
The reason Tucker Carlson liked it was that
it was the type of rhetoric that Carlson himself
uses to bamboozle his audience.
It's essentially what Trump is doing.
So we're looking at these things with completely
different standards.
So I don't know if the views are reconcilable,
quite frankly.
OK.
All right, well, thank you, Ben, I appreciate
your time.
All right.
No problem.
It's a very pessimistic response, but I think
it's the you know, it's the reality.